monsieur le ministre l'an 1 du nouveau
monde a vu l'avènement d'une oeuvre une
de vos oeuvres inachevées la conférence
nationale des territoires qui devait
selon le président de la république
bâtir un pacte de confiance
mais comme il arrive parfois hélas dans
une discussion les élus ne sont pas
venus vous dire ce que vous vouliez
entendre en revanche eux ont entendu vos
promesses rassurantes démenti avec une
célérité dont je dois le dire force
notre respect las de ne pas être écouté
les élus ont lancé un appel celui de
marseille restait quasiment sans réponse
si ce n'est un catalogue de bonnes
intentions
pourtant il avait pris monsieur le
ministre au sérieux le président de la
république quand sûrement dans un moment
d'égarement
celui-ci leur déclarer il y a un an au
congrès des maires je m'engage à une
chose c'est venir chaque année rendre
des comptes des engagements que je viens
de prendre
sincèrement monsieur le ministre on
aurait imaginé mieux que ce renoncement
pour soutenir les mères lorsque l'on
sait que la majorité d'entre eux ne
souhaite plus investir après 2020 le
candidat en marche rêvé de changer le
personnel politique le président macron
pourrait malheureusement être comblé ma
question est donc simple alors que le
dialogue est au point mort sans que de
réelles avancées n'ai vu le jour
qu'envisagez vous concrètement pour
l'avenir de nos communes merci sert
collègues
la parole est à monsieur marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur d'abord vous répondre parce que
vous interroger le gouvernement sur le
fait que le président de la république
ne soit pas venu devant le congrès des
maires
ils avaient dit qu'ils rendraient des
comptes
vous reconnaîtrez monsieur le sénateur
que l'exercice auquel s'est prêté le
président de la république hier qui est
un exercice de dialogue pas artificielle
qui est un exercice de dialogue direct
qui a d'ailleurs
excusez moi de vous le dire était
reconnu par tous les maires présents y
compris ceux qui étaient de votre
sensibilité politique politique était un
vrai dialogue est une vraie écoute et
non pas simplement un discours qu'il
faut faire parfois devant les
associations d'élus mais reconnaissons
le ne prête pas beaucoup au dialogue
alors vous m'interrogez par ailleurs sur
la conférence nationale des territoires
je vous rappelle d'abord que le sénat et
les associations d'élus étaient les
premiers demandeurs de l'organisation de
cette conférence nationale des
territoires lieu de dialogue entre
l'état et les collectivités locales
c'est une nouvelle méthode de travail et
reconnaissons effectivement que pour
l'instant pour des raisons diverses
certaine que vous avez ok d'autres elles
n'ont pas fonctionné alors le
gouvernement comme l'a dit le premier
ministre comme l'a dit le président la
république et comme lady les ministres
concernés il laisse la porte ouverte
il souhaite que la conférence nationale
des territoires reste est soit le lieu
du dialogue entre les collectivités
locales
il faut construire une forme de routine
de dialogue qu'elle soit régulière au
sein de cette conférence elle aura deux
formats cette conférence c'est ce que
dira aussi le premier ministre un format
complet présidé par le premier ministre
un ferme a restreint au bureau sous la
présidence de la ministre de la cohésion
des territoires qui réunira les
présidents des deux délégations
parlementaires et un représentant de
chaque association d'élus et je
souhaitais le gouvernement souhaite que
chaque association d'élus y soient
représentés et il soit présent et enfin
des groupes thématiques qui seront créés
pour sujet par sujet abordé les
questions territoriales concrètement
monsieur le sénateur je voulais
simplement vous répondre vous avez
raison il ya besoin de dialoguer et je
vais vous dire c'est les associations
d'élus le veulent je crois que les
maires des associations comme
l'association des maires de france le
demande
et je vais vous dire plus important
encore je crois que les citoyens ne
veulent pas ce qu'il y aurait rien de
pire que locaux et les collectivités
locales ne dialogue pas parce que nous
avons des sujets concrets
on ne comprendrait qu'il n'y ait pas de
dialogue je vous remercie merci monsieur
le ministre il ya une réplique oui
monsieur le ministre je crois qu'il est
temps d'arrêter la mystification arrêter
cette expression de dire que tout est
sous la table il est temps de passer aux
actes
aujourd'hui faites le en prenant vos
responsabilités comme nous avons pris
nos responsabilités en faisant trente
propositions pour revitaliser les
communes pour réaffirmer le principe de
subsidiarité pour adopter le principe
qui décident paix et pour revisiter re
toiletter comme vous l'avez dit la
fameuse loi nôtre qui est tant décrié je
crois qu'aujourd'hui à vous de prendre
vos responsabilités
à vous d'agir merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]